Шановні колеги в Запорізькій області
сьогодні Важка безпекова ситуація і
дійсно виявилося так що в місцевих радах
просто окрутилися зрадники які
представляють в тому числі заборонені
політичні партії шарійців опзж і нам
потрібно не тільки знаєте схемами
вирішувати це питання А вирішити широко
якщо є заборонені партії то депутати на
всіх рівнях мають полишити органи влади
в тому числі і в Верховній Раді України
в нас і досі представник опсж очолює
комітет свободи слова тому Ані комітет
Ані свободи слова але дуже важливо що
коли ми говоримо з вами про е-е
військово-цивільні адміністрації які
створюються говорити і про те що якщо
мова йде про такі регіони які
знаходяться в фронтовій зоні це одне
питання Коли сьогодні в Верховній Раді
України так само зареєстровані постанови
створення військових адміністрацій в
Києві де є обрана Влада де я мер де
працює місцева Влада то Це вже говорить
про наступ на місцеве самоврядування
знаєте коли багато влади і хочеться все
більше і більше І тому ми застерігаємо
колег в цій залі будь-які спроби
знищувати місцеве самоврядування
децентралізацію робити Ну і ключове
питання що якщо в нас Запорізькій в
Херсонській області де ми сьогодні
масово створюємо військові адміністрації
скільки зрадників То хто за це понесе
покарання наша фракція вимагає і ми
сподіваємося що ви всі підтримаєте це
питання викликати до зали Генерального
прокурора керівника служби безпеки
України і розказати така дебаканам як
так трапилося що найвищих кабінетах
країни сиділи кроти і зрадники російські
Агенти які призначались на найвищі
посади які на прямому були контакті з
кремлем щодня І це ФСБ які здали все що
тільки можна в Херсоні в Запоріжжі в
Донецькій в Луганській областях і в
самому Києві де ці люди сьогодні тому